okay hashtag early access provided by WB
hashtag WB sponsored yes okay uh I know
I'm a little late to the game I've been
so busy uh as I told you guys before
Warner Brothers flew myself in and and I
know he hates being called gyro
but I'm gonna call Matt anyway jr. uh
you know flu all of us in like like
David cage run cage games like a whole
bunch of us out to to check out like a
whole bunch of footage for the Lego DC
super villains game I'm going to guys
have played it the games by now since
the 16th it's pretty awesome like it's
actually pretty sweet um okay so here's
here's a cool thing so so one of my
favorite parts of the whole game was hub
world now I liked it because I literally
got to like just experiment the
characters and and literally just like
like check out all these different
characters like run around and test out
a whole bunch of things how world was
pretty awesome the campaign itself is
pretty sweet like it's it's it's a
pretty it's a really really really fun
game
um it's one reason why I like it so much
is because like okay I'll about you guys
but like for me like running around as
running around is like eobard thawne
it's kind of cool I kind of like be in a
bed super powers I'd be a terrible
person anyway that's one tell you guys
about that make sure you guys go check
it out and yeah I feel like we should
live stream the game at some point on my
channel on comments explain it's a
common channel why not live stream the
game anyway I'm gonna bounce off here
let's get into the video about the flash
and that will catch you all later purse
so for the character of Jay things were
the things were interesting you know to
me there's always been a big difference
between being recognizable and being
popular you know and since that Jay
Garrick never released I mean he sold a
lot I mean relative to today Jay Garrick
sold a ton of comics you're talking
about a quarter of a million copies sold
per month most likely I mean back then
the numbers for for exactly what was
sold back then or a little murky as best
I can tell all you can ever really do is
find the total number of comics that
were sold for the year and then just
divide by 12 get an average
along those lines but you know for Jay
Garrick's character originally he was a
crapshoot
right because it down you look at you
look at you know all-american
publications back in 1938 actually the
1940 and and you look at max games and
and he was a guy who had gone out on a
limb who'd gone to Harry donenfeld you
know over national had lipo vacations
and said you know I went alone in order
to launch all-american publications and
the hope was that it would succeed but
there was no guarantee that it would and
and the guys over there knew what they
were getting into
you know max gains and she'll the mayor
and all those guys they knew what they
were getting into they knew that they
were really going for broke that if they
if they launched their publication house
and it didn't work that Harry donenfeld
would write them off and and they would
probably never be able to get another
gig you know launching comics anywhere
else because if he considered failures
they'd be considered you know a
non-viable entity because one thing to
bear in mind is this is important to
keep much is it back then you know by
the time the flash came out in nineteen
forty you're talking about a genre that
had been around for like two years and
so most companies out there considered
it to be a trend considered to be a
passing thing that within five or six
years that comic books would have run
their course and that would be the end
of it and for the most part they weren't
totally wrong they were they were
actually kind of right in terms of
predicting that of course they didn't
really predict the mid-1950s and Jewish
works and all then but the fact remains
that that according to the to the
stories that are told you could take
them for what they're worth but
according to the stories that we're told
uh what you had is you had a Sheldon
Meyer who was the editor for for
all-american comics ya Gardner Fox and
you had Harry Lampert and then three of
them were sitting around trying to find
a way to launch a comic that would that
would draw in readers but would also
basically say like we're all American
comics were all American publications
and we're here to stay like we're not
going anywhere
and so they were essentially looking at
like Superman because remember he was
the template Superman was a standard by
which all other superheroes were drawn
and so the the idea was to parcel out
his powers and so what they did is they
they looked at the various things that
Superman was capable of you know bullets
bouncing off of them and
and you know more powerful and
locomotive and things like that and they
drew on speed and they said we want to
create a character who's super fast now
that's the stuff of legend I mean
honestly in this day and age you would
have had a baby in the room in order to
really know how that discussion unfolded
which is something that I'd be kind of
curious to see but regardless you know
by whatever manner and whatever means it
resulted in the creation of Jay Garrick
and so that came out of a really really
you know came to us in flash Comics
number one now originally the flash
comics for an anthology series they were
uh there was it was literally a 64 page
book thirteen pages of which contains
stories about Jay Garrick and that was
one of the biggest issues that they had
to deal with at the outset was how to
fill 13 pages with a guy who could move
super fast because the one question that
there was probably asked right off the
bat and if not asked by by Myer and and
Fox and and and Lampert certainly would
have been asked by fans is how is it
that the fastest man alive doesn't just
end his stories like that in the blink
of an eye what stops him from just like
running in grabbing the criminals and
then leaving you know how can you fill
up 13 pages and so so the first task was
to do that in such a way that it was
believable and so what they did is they
they started out by by of course getting
us the origin story which that was part
and parcel back then you basically had
like a three-point narrative when it
came to publishing stories about comic
book superheroes you had the origin
story which is to say what happened that
led them to gaining powers you had the
event but whereby they like they trigger
and become superheroes and then you felt
you know flesh out there they're
supporting monster and so with with
those three things kind of laid out we
first got his origin story of course as
most people know I really those who know
about Jay Garrick anyway that he was
basically just some kid who was working
in a lab and he essentially breathed in
you know heavy water datoria
sitting on those lines and and the
result was it he passed out and the
professor came in and he was freaking
out oh my god oh that's good and and
that led to the professor taking him to
the hospital which led to Jay Garrick
waking up and realizing he could run
super fast that goes into his actions of
becoming a superhero and that's where
John Williamson
Ansari John Williams become so important
for for Sheldon Mayer when he looked at
the superhero genre
one of the big issues he saw was that
there was not a lot of forward thinking
well you know when it came to women in
comics they were for the most part
confined to your stereotypical role they
were confined to being like supporting
characters and that was it
say what you want about Lois Lane and
she there's a lot of history there you
know she's the first lady of comics and
she was the quintessential damsel in
distress you say what you want to about
the character she was based off of you
know torchy Blaine and so on and so
forth at the end of the day she was
always rescued by Superman then you know
should we get her softener a be all Lois
is in over her head you know I just like
women do you know they they leap before
they look you know and then they then
suddenly know she's on the on the edge
of a rooftop and she gets pushed shocked
by Lex Luthor and Superman comes flying
in this taser and and because of that
there was really no I guess there was
there really didn't seem to be any
emphasis on creating women in superhero
comics that were worth a bit you know to
be honest and so so Sheldon Myer walked
away from them and said that's old hat
thinking and so John Williams was a
total shift away from the Lois Lane you
know Lois Lane standard in the sense
that when you got to the point in the
story where J develop his powers he
tells Joan almost immediately and they
she's his girlfriend of it you know so I
mean he goes to try off the football so
on and so forth gets the affections of
Joan but he basically tells Joan almost
immediately I'm the flash and one of the
first things she says or you know at
some point in the story one thing she
says is that he's an idiot for using his
powers to just play football like why
not use those powers to make the world a
better place if he's capable of so much
make the world better and so she
immediately shifted away from all help
me flash help me you know and turn into
you need to get your act together which
was actually a pretty forward-thinking
idea that's something you wouldn't
really see in terms of women taking on
this empowerment wall until you got to
Wonder Woman you know some year and a
half two years later and so so following
that Jay goes on to become the flash he
basically Dawn's this this metal helmet
that belonged to his father there's some
wings attached to it and any becomes a
fighter in Keystone City originally it
was in New York but he basically becomes
a fighter in Keystone
now this leads to this leads to Joan
actually leaving she ends up going off
to Washington to work with her dad or
someone those lines her father's kidnap
she goes back to Keystone she hits up JJ
rescues her father she moves back to
Keystone and there are a couple forever
and so so following this with Jay being
well really with him with him being
solidified and in that fashion there was
there was definitely readership there
there was there were certainly an
audience there there was not a huge
audience but there was a big audience
nonetheless and when I say huge I'm
really using Superman and Batman is kind
of the standard for what a popular hero
was because they've stood the test of
time and when you're talking about them
at their most popular they were selling
hundreds of thousands of comics a month
I mean they were they weren't selling
boatloads of comic books he was
absolutely insane you know the sales of
comics are in the Golden Age we'll never
get back to that point again they'll
never be a time in in the United States
or really in the in the world in human
history when we will ever reach the the
height of comic book sales what we did
and the Golden Age because they were so
new and they were so fresh nowadays
comic books are just a thing that's
there but but back then it was it was a
whole different beast and so so
following this the Sheldon Meyer had
this idea to to try a team-based book
but in reality the roster of all
American publications it wasn't really
big enough to hold its own because again
Wonder Woman hadn't been introduced by
this point and you had like green ivory
I'm sorry Green Lantern the idea
original Allen Scott and yet a couple of
the characters here and there but they
weren't really named draws but on the
other side of the other side of the road
you know metaphorically you had national
allied publications they had Superman
and they had Batman and they they were
creating Johnny quick you know as
because of the Flash's popularity they
created Johnny quick quality comics
created Quicksilver max mercury you had
like all these different characters you
know that were coming out of the
woodwork and so Sheldon Meyer kind of a
oh well he alongside Gardner Fox
orchestrated this kind of coming
together the first stage and what would
eventually turn into a merger between
all-american publications and national
allied publications and this came in the
form of a line of Commerce called all
star and all star was a quarterly common
meaning it came out four times a year
and and this basically saw the the the
standout members of more fun comics and
adventure comics on the national allied
side and the all-american self-titled
comic all-american comics
flash comics being brought together and
and when that happened Jay Garrick was
made like the leader of the team and
that was kind of designed to hit on Jay
Garrick fans who of course you know
we're pretty substantial that point in
time not the biggest but you know pretty
substantial in that point in time and
and it was a way to basically say like
hey here are all these superheroes
fighting together now JSA was resounding
ly successful I mean there was there was
no doubting the popularity of something
like that what does that she got him
interesting because the the the whole
concept of like a tried and true shared
universe didn't really exist until
Batman and Superman first crossed over
and Superman volume 1 number 75 and so
we were talking about moving things in
that direction and then you know what
would later become you know DC Comics
basically saying hey look you know
metropolis is here and Gotham's here and
they're on the same earth than they
cross over and they meet and so on and
so forth that changed everything
but at that point in time with JSA there
was a big step in and of itself it was a
very big gamble because nobody knew if
it was gonna work if it was gonna be
believable or any of those things and it
turned out to be a huge successful move
but the biggest thing that that you know
both All American and National had at
the time is they had this added
editorial mandate and the editorial
mandate said to not over expose
characters and so Batman and Superman
were the huge stars and Jay Garrick was
rapidly rising in prominence and so the
question was do we bring all of them
onto the team Batman if Superman were
definitive no I mean you had actually
common actually comics in Detective
Comics which were monthly comics you had
a Batman and Superman which were
quarterly and then you had like flash
comics with Jay Garrick and so they
threw Jay garner onto the team they
threw like you know like Spectre and and
they threw a handful where they cared is
on the team it was highly successful and
in response to that the question was
asked by Sheldon Mayer can we launch a
flash solo series and that was really
when the test came in because initially
for the first couple issues it was a bit
rocky you know Sheldon Mayer brought in
Sheldon Sheldon mold off to draw the
first two issues and it wasn't hugely
successful it wasn't it wasn't anywhere
near as big as you would have expected
it to be instead it was just kind of a
you know it was it there's really any
chemistry there and so Sheldon Meyer
gets rid of Sheldon malt off and he
brings in a guy by the name of
of ever every Everett Hibbard he brings
him in and has him write the whole thing
in Everett Herbert's time on on the
flash was marked by some like really
like definitive drawing for his
character you know a view Google search
Jay Garrick it'll be Everett Hitler
drawings that you essentially pick up
but because of the fact that that having
a character and three different
publications was a huge no-no due to
overexposure what they did is they wrote
Jay Garrick out of the JSA and basically
in the first issue of a solo series a
JSA comes along and they say hey
congratulations on attaining honorary
membership basically congratulations on
being retired from the team and it's
kind of an awkward situation but but Jay
Gary basically leaves a JSA an honorary
status essentially meant like hey you'll
only ever really come and fight
alongside the team when like [ __ ] really
pops off and because it never really did
there was never really a reason for him
to be part of it and so he goes on to
his own solo series and that was very
successful because it helped to branch
out into expand on the Jay Garrick
mythos even more and between the flash
comics anthology series his time on JSA
and his solo series there were a lot of
leering questions that were answered one
of the big questions a lot of fans had
for example is you know how is it that
Jay Garrick isn't known yeah I'm sorry
how is it how was his identity unknown
because back then identities were tried
and true they were a part of the
superhero mythos you know Batman took
off the cloak and cowl he was Bruce
Wayne Superman put on glasses he became
he put on BB you know he became Clark
Kent you know with that kind of a
situation the Jay Garrick didn't have a
mask there was no real way for him to
hide his identity or his face and so
what DC did is they came back or I guess
you know all American they came back and
they said well actually he vibrates his
face super fast and that's how nobody's
able to see him you know between those
three lines of publications that he
spent his time and they did things like
like flesh out his stories and say well
we can make these last by having him you
know vibrate super fast or he looks
invisible and then in turn like knock
things over to trick people took
criminals into believing that the place
is haunted or something along those
lines and it was it was a very very
smart move because where he was
originally rooted and being a farm were
not really a super serious character but
your traditional superhero by the time
he got a solo series World War 1 was in
full swing and the consular World War
two either was in full swing and become
the country was pretty dark in terms of
you know or pretty bleak in terms of the
whole war effort and everybody
contributing to it and constant
propaganda and in the United States and
so on and so forth and so what Sheldon
Meyer did is he actually ordered Gardner
Fox you're not really ordered so much as
I guess directed Gardner Fox to start
shifting the tone of the comics to make
them a little more comedic and so you
started getting the introduction of guys
like you know what is the three dimwits
which are basically like these three
goofballs that would appear pretty
consistently over the course of those
stories and they were based on of course
the Three Stooges but they started he
started doing things like throwing pie
in the faces of like criminals and so on
and so forth and it was just a way to
kind of laugh you know to get a good
laugh out of people and it was the right
kind of humor at the right kind of time
which helped to push his comics even
further and so by this point you know
because of the fact that he was he
proved to be so popular in in his own
solo series eventually DC used him to
launch a third publication I'm sorry not
DC all-american use him watch a third
publication called comic havoc late and
comic havoc late largely involved
himself Wonder Woman by this point in
time and either Green Lantern or Aquaman
I kept aloft on my head but it was used
to launch it to kind of you know boost
popularity for those three characters
and then he was thrown back onto JSA and
so it's one of those things where he was
it was like hey look like this guy is
essentially everyone you know it's this
version you know this this flash guy the
fastest man alive there's all over the
place and for a time it proved to be
successful now what remains to be
debated and this is really the
discussion a lot of people have in terms
of why Jay Garrick went under is whether
or not it was because of the
decision-making of Sheldon Mayer or I
get that you know so tomorrow or whether
or not it was because of the lack of
popularity in comics in reality a lot of
people point to the lack of popularity
in comics that by the time World War two
ended that that comic book readership
had basically dropped off superhero
themes had essentially gone away because
they were part and parcel to the war
effort and people didn't want to have
anything to do with that they didn't
want to have anything to do with
superheroes fighting the Axis powers and
so on and so forth you know even though
Jay Garrick stories largely dealt with
fighting criminals nobody really wanted
that and so that was the real test of
how popular Jay Garrick was because in
1948 showed a Meyer left he took off
went to go focus on his own personal
project which meant that from that point
going forward it was anybody's guess
what was gonna happen it happened to Jay
the following year he started getting
all his comics canceled
and by that point you know all American
and national had merged into Detective
Comics Incorporated in a DC Comics and
so they they went through and it was
literally it was I mean it was across
the board it was it was just heads were
rolling I mean people were just being
put on the chopping block and that was a
crazy thing because once it smoke clear
you know over the span of about three
years between 1948 and 1951 once it's
smoke cleared and and it was all said
and done then the question was was Jay
Garrick as popular as people thought he
was absolutely not because when it was
when when it was all said and done Jay
Garrick's head was laying in that basket
of the guillotine just like you know
alongside Captain America and name of
the Submariner and and Hawkman and Green
Lantern Alan Scott and a whole host of
other characters who just didn't make
the cut because they just weren't
popular enough and so that was that was
the whole basis behind Jay you know
ultimately he ended up just kind of kind
of going away but no I mean you know
again it was it was one of those crap
shoots because no one really knew the
direction things were gonna go in and no
you know Jay Garrick was expected to
never be seen or heard from again nobody
ever expected to hear from his character
again which we know that's not the case
I mean of course he was eliminated in
1951 ten years later he showed up
alongside Barry Allen you know and all
that was orchestrated by Julius Schwartz
the guy who started the second
Renaissance of comic books when he
blended science fiction themes with
superhero things and of course gave us
you know really took off with that with
Barry Allen and and DC showcase number
four but ya know I mean Jay Garrick's
one of those legacy characters you know
old man flash the guy's been around for
a long long time and and he's just one
of those guys that that the fans really
seem to latch on to if for no other
reason in the fact that he's just been
around for so long he's a the original
speedster he's the original flash and
and ya for that sub-sect of the cannibal
community for those fans he will always
hold a special place
[Music]